[Música]
una lucha que se mantiene cada 28 de
septiembre se conmemora el día de Acción
global por el aborto legal seguro y
accesible América Latina ha tenido
importantes avances en cuanto a la
legalización de la interrupción del
embarazo sin embargo aún genera debate
creo que es un día muy importante
especialmente para
[Música]
nuestra red donde no se tienen las
mismas provisiones legales alrededor del
acceso al aborto no y y y justamente
frente a los avances que ha habido
especialmente Durante los últimos años
pero que igualmente siguen existiendo
retrocesos o intentos de retroceso
América Latina tiene grandes contrastes
en cuanto a la regularización del aborto
recientemente países como Colombia
Argentina y siete de los 32 estados de
México obtuvieron una flexibilización de
la interrupción del embarazo Pero hay
otros estados donde el panorama es
incierto países como Haití y El Salvador
prohíben el aborto de manera absoluta en
este último se castiga a las mujeres
hasta con 50 años de cárcel y 12 al
personal médico que realice la
intervención por su parte Honduras
además de prohibir el aborto castiga
incluso la anticoncepción oral de
emergencia en Perú desde 1924 hace casi
100 años la ley del aborto se intactas
otros países como Venezuela y Nicaragua
aún están muy lejos de llegar a un
consenso mientras Ecuador Brasil
Paraguay y Bolivia permiten el
procedimiento bajo ciertas causales que
los estados tienen que cumplir
independientemente de quién está al
mando es con sus obligaciones
internacionales frente a garantizar el
servicio de aborto para todas las
personas que lo necesiten pues Porque
además es justamente se trata de que no
tiene que ver con que si estamos de
acuerdo o no con el aborto a nadie se le
está obligando a que tengan aborto se
trata que es un servicio de salud
esencial que cualquier persona en edad
reproductiva puede necesitar a lo largo
de su vida Aunque cada vez hay más
acceso a la salud reproductiva en la
región es una lucha por la cual el
movimiento feminista no se cansa de
batallar